Copernicus: A Revolution of Astronomical Proportions
It is very rare that a book can come out and
single-handedly change humanity’s understanding
of the world.
But
in 1543, De revolutionibus orbium coelestium
(“On the Revolutions of the Heavenly Spheres”)
did just that.
It was a book by Polish astronomer Nicolaus
Copernicus in which he presented his model
of a heliocentric Universe - one which did
not place the Earth at the center of it all,
anymore.
Instead, it had been replaced with the Sun
which was now, more or less, at the heart
of the Universe, and all the stars and planets
in the sky revolved around it.
It was a revolutionary thought, one that challenged
well-established notions that had been around
for over a millennium.
It wasn’t immediately accepted, or even
understood, for that matter.
But it served its purpose in presenting an
alternative to a grand idea that seemed immovable
from the public consciousness.
Many others followed who popularized, improved
and heavily modified the heliocentric model
first outlined by Copernicus, but it still
remains to this day one of the core concepts
of our reality.
Early Life
Nicolaus Copernicus, or Mikołaj Kopernik
in its original Polish, was born on February
19, 1473, in the city of Toruń in the recently
established territory of Royal Prussia.
Prior to this, the region had been part of
the State of the Teutonic Order, formed by
crusader knights during the 13th century.
However, following the Second Peace of Toruń
in 1466, Royal Prussia became an autonomous
dependency of the Kingdom of Poland.
Copernicus was the son of Nicolaus the Elder
and Barbara Watzenrode.
According to records, Nicolaus’s father
was a successful merchant, as was his grandfather
on his mother’s side.
Originally established in Krakow, Nicolaus
the Elder decided to relocate the family to
Toruń before the birth of his namesake.
Nicolaus was the youngest in the family with
an older brother and two older sisters.
The family last name comes from Koperniki,
the village where his paternal ancestors came
from.
Throughout his lifetime, Copernicus was rather
lax when it came to the spelling of his name
and used, at least, three different variants.
Studies in Poland
It is unlikely that Copernicus would have
had the opportunity to pursue a life of science
if not for his maternal uncle, Lucas Watzenrode
the Younger.
The senior Nicolaus died when his son was
ten years old and his uncle took him and his
siblings in his care.
He ensured a good education for young Copernicus.
There are no records to suggest exactly what
that entailed, particularly in his early years,
but historians have speculated that the young
man most likely followed an educational path
similar to that of his uncle.
This would involve studies at St. John’s
School in Toruń, and then the Cathedral School
in Włocławek in order to prepare Copernicus
for entrance to the University of Krakow,
Watzenrode’s alma mater.
Image suggestion: Lucas Watzenrode
We do know that Copernicus enrolled in the
school in Krakow, today called the Jagiellonian
University, in the winter of 1491.
Surprisingly, he first studied arts, but also
decided to learn mathematics in order to take
advantage of the fact that the school had
some of the best mathematicians in Europe.
This was also the time when he started going
by the Latin version of his name instead of
his Polish birth name.
One of his educators was Albert Brudzewski,
a math teacher who also liked to give lectures
on astronomy and Aristotelian philosophy.
He was likely among the first to spur young
Copernicus’s interest in studying the stars.
The Polish prodigy quickly proved to have
a knack for mathematics and astronomy and
it was during his time at the University of
Krakow that he wrote his first observations
on the subjects.
Nicolaus left the university in 1495 without
a degree and returned home to his uncle.
A few years earlier, Lucas Watzenrode the
Younger became the Prince-Bishop of Warmia,
a special region that was under direct authority
of the pope.
Unsurprisingly, he wanted to secure a canonical
position for his nephew.
However, for unclear reasons, Copernicus’s
assignment was delayed so, instead, his uncle
sent him to continue his studies in Italy
at the Bologna University.
Continued Education in Italy
Technically, Copernicus went to Italy to study
canon law so he could advance his position
in the church, something that would have been
almost guaranteed given his uncle’s high
standing.
However, in the years spent in Bologna, Nicolaus
became more interested in continuing his studies
of astronomy and the humanities.
There, he met Domenico Maria Novara, a famed
astronomer of his time who became Copernicus’s
teacher and even took him on as an assistant.
Copernicus traveled for a bit to Rome where
he spent the jubilee year 1500.
By this point, he had become proficient enough
in astronomy that he started giving lectures.
The next year, the young scientist returned
to Warmia, but the stay was short-lived.
He convinced the Church that he should also
study medicine, so he was given another two-year
leave to go back to Italy.
This time, he enrolled at the University of
Padua from 1501 to 1503.
Like before, Copernicus was not one to limit
his knowledge to the intended curriculum and
pursued multiple interests which, of course,
included astronomy, but also ancient Greek
which would give him access to many of the
seminal astronomical works from ancient times.
Back to Warmia
Despite all of his extracurricular activities,
the second time around in Italy Nicolaus managed
to graduate as a Doctor of Law.
With his studies complete, the 30-year-old
Copernicus returned to Warmia where he would
spend most of the next 40 years.
He became his uncle’s right-hand man.
Officially, he was the Prince-Bishop’s assistant
and physician, although he was involved with
most of the duties of his uncle, be they religious,
economical, political, or administrative.
It is unclear if he was ever actually ordained
as a priest, but it does not seem like he
ever took orders in the Catholic Church.
With all of his responsibilities, Copernicus
was a busy man and was on the road a lot as
part of his uncle’s retinue.
Even so, in the eight years or so that he
served Lucas Watzenrode until his death, he
still managed to write a small precursor to
his later work that would revolutionize astronomy.
The Almagest
We should probably take a minute to look at
humanity’s understanding of the Universe
prior to Copernicus to truly get a sense of
how influential he was in the grand scheme
of things.
Before he published his seminal work, the
astronomical world believed in a geocentric
model.
This meant that the Earth was at the center
of the Universe and everything else - moons,
planets, stars, and our Sun - they all orbited
us.
Image suggestion: Claudius Ptolemy
This belief appeared in many ancient cultures,
including the Greeks.
They all presented, more or less, the basic
tenets of geocentrism, but there was no widely-accepted
system.
That is until an astronomer from Alexandria
named Claudius Ptolemy wrote the Almagest
sometime around the mid second century AD.
A quick note here: even if he is sometimes
referred to simply as Ptolemy and he was from
Alexandria, he should not be confused with
any of the members of the Ptolemaic Dynasty
that ruled over Egypt for almost 300 years
and also included Cleopatra.
The astronomer wrote his seminal work which
he called Mathematike Syntaxis or The Mathematical
Compilation.
Despite its name, it was mainly about the
motions of the stars and planets and, as it
grew in influence, it became known as The
Greatest Compilation.
The name was then shortened to The Greatest
and, later, when it made its way into other
cultures, it was more commonly referred to
by its Latin transliteration of Almagest.
Although the Almagest consisted of 13 books,
it had five main points.
The celestial realm was spherical.
Our Earth was a sphere, at the center of this
realm, and did not move.
And, in relation to the distance to all the
fixed stars, the Earth had no appreciable
size and must have been treated as a mathematical
point.
Ptolemy’s ideas were popular enough that,
eventually, the Ptolemaic model became synonymous
with geocentrism.
It was the accepted truth for 1,300 years,
but it still had its detractors.
Even before Copernicus, there were other astronomers,
particularly in the medieval Arab world, who
saw flaws in Ptolemy’s system.
However, none of them went so far as to propose
an alternative that completely negated it.
The Commentariolus
Because the Almagest had been around for well
over a thousand years and traveled from culture
to culture, it has been translated many times
over from one language to another.
Written originally in Greek, it was converted
into Arabic by Muslim scholars and, later,
medieval Europeans used that version and translated
it into Latin.
Many astronomers prior to Copernicus thought
that it might contain inaccuracies not necessarily
due to Ptolemy’s faulty ideas, but due to
poor translations.
One of them was a German scientist called
Regiomontanus.
He obtained the original Greek work and concluded
that there were errors, in fact, which belonged
to Ptolemy rather than the translators who
came after him.
He published the Summary of Ptolemy’s Almagest
several years before Copernicus was born.
The Polish astronomer read Regiomontanus’s
book.
He had also been spurred on by his teacher
in Bologna, Domenico Maria Novara, who was
another skeptic who doubted Ptolemy’s infallibility.
Nicolaus was determined to study the ancient
Greek astronomer himself and draw his own
conclusions.
Sometime before 1514, Copernicus wrote a treatise
called the Commentariolus (Little Commentary).
Consisting of eight chapters, it made arguments
for seven postulates that laid down the groundwork
for his heliocentric model.
Crucially, they said that the Earth is not
the center of the Universe and that there
is no fixed point around which all other celestial
bodies orbit.
The paper got some things right, such as the
fact that the Moon is the only sphere that
orbits the Earth and that the distance from
the Earth to the Sun is insignificant compared
to the distance to all the other stars.
Copernicus also placed the known planets in
the right order from the Sun and calculated
their orbital periods with pretty impressive
accuracy.
It also got some things wrong, such as placing
the Sun near the center of the Universe and
concluding that the stars are immovable.
Even so, these radical ideas were very far
removed from the accepted model of Ptolemy.
Copernicus saw his Commentariolus as just
an outline for a much grander work.
Therefore, he did not make many copies of
his treatise and only shared it with a few
other people.
It was never published during his lifetime.
Among those who received a copy of the paper,
the Commentariolus garnered a good reception.
It was of particular interest to Nikolaus
von Schönberg, the Archbishop of Capua and
later a Cardinal of Pope Paul III.
In 1536, he wrote a letter to Copernicus requesting
a copy of his treatise.
He praised the astronomer’s “so fine a
talent” and expressed great interest in
his revolutionary ideas.
Copernicus later included this letter in his
magnum opus, De revolutionibus orbium coelestium.
In the Meantime
The Polish scientist was not one to rush things.
After he wrote the Commentariolus, he would
spend another two decades working on his main
treatise.
It would be another decade after that that
it would finally get printed, in the same
year that Copernicus died.
He was mainly concerned with his astronomical
observations, but Copernicus also had plenty
of administrative duties to attend to which
ate up a lot of his time.
His uncle, the Prince-Bishop of Warmia, died
in 1512 and Nicolaus participated in the election
of his successor.
There were also other issues that required
his attention such as renewed war with the
Teutonic Order and internal strife among the
leaders of Warmia over how loyal and servient
they should be towards the Polish Crown.
Image suggestion: Copernicus tower
https://commons.wikimedia.org/wiki/File:Copernicus_tower.jpg
Around this time, Copernicus also relocated
permanently to the city of Frombork where
he lived and worked for the remainder of his
life.
He not only had a house, but was also allowed
to purchase the northwestern tower within
the stronghold walls to use as his observatory.
Copernicus the Economist
Often overlooked is Copernicus’s contribution
to economics.
As mentioned before, he wore many hats as
his uncle’s right-hand man.
When Lucas Watzenrode passed away, his nephew
proved himself adept enough that he continued
to be a major influence in the administration
of Warmia.
In 1526, he was asked by King Sigismund I
of Poland to write a paper on monetary reform
which was a hot button topic at the time.
Copernicus wrote Monetae cudendae ratio (“On
the Minting of Coin”).
The gist of it is exemplified by the principle
that “bad money drives out good”.
In this case, “good” money refers to coins
whose face value is roughly the same as their
commodity value granted by the value of the
metals they are made from.
“Bad” money refers to coins that not only
have a significant disparity between the two
values, but are also put in circulation alongside
“good” money.
A bit unfairly, the postulate is known today
as Gresham’s Law, named in the 19th century
after 16th century English financier Sir Thomas
Gresham.
However, Copernicus published his work on
the subject decades before Gresham.
Delays
By the early 1530s, Copernicus’s seminal
work De revolutionibus orbium coelestium was
finished, more or less.
He kept on making changes to it until his
death, but it could have been ready for printing,
if he desired it.
However, the Polish astronomer kept on delaying
the publishing of his book and, even today,
scholars argue over the true reason for this
behavior.
Some feel like it had to do with the Church
and that Copernicus feared the consequences
that might occur if his work was deemed heretical.
After all, things did not work out so well
for one of the strongest advocates of Copernicanism,
Galileo.
Almost a hundred years later, his ideas were
considered heresy by the Roman Inquisition
because heliocentrism contradicted the Holy
Scripture and, as a result, Galileo was forced
to recant his views and he spent the last
decade of his life under house arrest.
Others believe that Copernicus was reticent
to publish his findings because he feared
any kind of criticism or outright rejection
of his ideas.
The Book
Ever since Copernicus wrote the Commentariolus,
he was careful to share his work only with
friends and other trusted astronomers.
He did the same thing with De revolutionibus
orbium coelestium prior to printing, but word
of mouth spread and others heard of it.
Bishops knew about it.
So did the Pope.
Initial reactions seemed to be either of approval
or indifference.
There were plenty of people, astronomers included,
who disagreed with his ideas, but no one was
beating down the door of his house to burn
Copernicus at the stake just yet.
A contributing factor had to be the fact that
his book was not exactly “reader friendly”.
Copernicus believed that “mathematics is
written for mathematicians” so laymen were
unlikely to get much out of it, even if they
read it.
It was up to other astronomers who came afterwards
to champion his cause and bring Copernican
beliefs to the wider masses (and suffer the
consequences for it).
The basic idea was the one initially outlined
in Commentariolus.
According to heliocentrism, the Earth was
no longer special - it was just another planet
that orbited the Sun.
Rheticus
One of the aforementioned astronomers who
became followers of Copernicus was his pupil,
Georg Joachim de Porris, better known as Rheticus.
Image: Rheticus
When he was young, Rheticus obtained the patronage
of Philipp Melanchthon, an influential Protestant
reformer and Martin Luther’s “right-hand
man”.
He arranged for the young scientist to go
study with some of the greatest astronomers
of the day, but it was Copernicus who garnered
his true interest.
In fact, he might have played the most important
part in making sure that De revolutionibus
orbium coelestium saw the light of day, after
Copernicus, of course.
He kept on pestering and encouraging his teacher
to publish his work.
In 1540, with the permission of Copernicus,
Rheticus wrote and published Narratio Prima
(“The First Report”).
It was an abstract of his teacher’s heliocentric
theory and served well as an introduction
to Copernicus’s book which would be released
a few years later.
So, yes, the first ever published work on
the Copernican model did not even belong to
Copernicus.
Even so, nobody raised their pitchforks in
anger when this work came out, and this proved
to be instrumental in finally convincing the
Polish astronomer to put his own book into
print.
Ad Lectorem
In 1543, Copernicus finally consented to having
his magnum opus published.
He sent it via Rheticus to German printer
Johannes Petreius and the project was overseen
by theologian Andreas Osiander.
He had previously conversed with Copernicus
and showed an interest in his hypotheses,
but it is not clear if he undertook this task
on his own or at someone else’s behest.
Image: Andreas Osiander
The book was divided into six sections, mimicking
closely the layout of Ptolemy’s Almagest.
It was dedicated to Pope Paul III and contained
a preface which argued that mathematics was
the basis used for these new ideas and not
physics so mathematics should be used to understand
them.
These were all efforts by Copernicus to make
his work less controversial in the eyes of
the Catholic Church.
When De revolutionibus orbium coelestium finally
came out, Copernicus couldn’t help but notice
that the preface also contained a letter that
he did not write or even know about.
It was titled Ad lectorem de hypothesibus
huius operis (“To the reader concerning
the hypotheses of this work”) and had actually
been written by Osiander and added to the
book without Copernicus’s consent.
The addition advised that the ideas put forward
in the book are not necessarily true, or even
probable, for that matter, but they are useful
for making observations and calculating distances.
It anticipated that scholars would be “deeply
offended” by the notion that the Earth moves
while the Sun is at rest in the center of
the Universe and came to the defence of the
author who “has done nothing blameworthy”.
The thing about the letter was that Osiander
wrote it anonymously and did not sign anything
at the end.
To the reader, it looked like Copernicus himself
was the author of Ad Lectorem who, seemingly,
didn’t believe his own theories.
Reactions and Receptions
Copernicus wasn’t around for long to see
the impact of his work.
He died of a stroke soon after De revolutionibus
orbium coelestium was published in his home
in Frombork.
He was 70 years old and a legend says that
he passed away right after being presented
with the final printed pages of the book he
worked on for most of his life.
As far as Ad Lectorem was concerned, Rheticus
and supporters of Copernicus made sure that
others knew that the Polish scientist was
not the one who wrote it.
Osiander’s reason for writing it still remains
a mystery, though.
Some argue that he himself did not believe
in Copernicus’s theories and was offended
by their heretical implications and wanted
to dismiss the book as a legitimate work of
science.
Others believe the exact opposite - Osiander
tried to minimize the negative reactions to
the book as much as possible.
Your guess is as good as anyone’s regarding
his true intentions.
De revolutionibus orbium coelestium won’t
be cracking any best-seller lists anytime
soon.
It sold terrible because, as we mentioned
before, it was very technical and not meant
for anyone who didn’t have a solid background
in mathematics or astronomy.
The few copies that were sold, though, reached
the right people and, in the decades that
followed, many scientists were converted to
Copernicanism.
Computations using this new model were, unsurprisingly,
more accurate, and proved very useful for
new astronomical tables.
Also unsurprising was the religious reaction.
Protestants were the ones most fired up against
Copernicus.
Martin Luther objected that his work went
against Holy Scripture that said that “Joshua
bid the sun to stand still and not the earth”.
He believed Copernicus was a fool who wanted
“to turn the whole art of astronomy upside-down”.
The Catholic Church had a similar, but much
slower reaction, and put De revolutionibus
orbium coelestium on the Index of Forbidden
Books in the early 17th century, almost 70
years after it originally came out.
Try as they might, though, the idea of heliocentrism
was now in the open.
This probably meant little to the common man,
but more and more scientists looked at it
and realized that it made sense.
It was a bell that could not be unrung and
our understanding of the Universe grew and
evolved from that premise to what
we have today.